hallo herr darf ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine damen und herren zu
einem spiel auf einem kanal das auf
youtube noch nie jemand gebracht hat
aber vor allem ich doch nie gebracht
habe und zwar ist es weil wir waren auf
wolke plus er hat geschrieben
[Musik]
sechs buchstaben ein knödel
ich werde gar die es geht um diese
person nicht ob dass sie hunden
er wurde angezeigt und ich hab ja ich
dachte wir wären eigentlich richtig gut
wir sind noch zu dumm zu schreiben
[Musik]
schraubenzieher sagte jetzt was es ist
ja das was ist das hier ein schlüssel
was ist das hier alter sagt er mich so
schüssel schrauben im winter skifahren
mastercard
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gut gezeichnet ich hab das skispringen
schon geschrieben nein nein skispringen
geschrieben max hat einfach doppelt so
viele punkte wie ich ampel ist mein gott
habe beleuchtung mein gott ich habe
[Musik]
das ist es auch nicht ich hab ich hab es
ja ok warte das was ich jetzt hab ich
vier burschen weiter gefragt ob ich
versuchen ob ich noch ein bisschen
besser zeichnen kann
[Musik]
firstnews von james mittelmeeres
ich hab's ja hast du immer vor mir sein
pakete wie es ist der rot-roten amaro
geht's gut ich hab ich habe mich
verarschen oktober trennten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich kann da nicht mehr zu zeichnen hätte
ich kann das hier warte so echt gut an
alle die gerade zu gucken oder die
gerade schon wissen es ist mit olaf ich
habe sie habe sie habe ich hab's mit dem
löffel mann erhöht da ist was drin und
zwar von damit tag des wassers ist wie
very easy ist dass ich hab's ist das a
day sah ich bin erster ich bin erster
oma im golf on board scheinen zum geier
entrückt
oh mein gott ich habe nein nein wäre ja
das ist sie nicht
junge sagt sie das studium halt was ist
der erste teil das wort gab ok kanarien
[Musik]
gross großen gebäude
na ja nein nein
die krank ich bin unter war heftig
gerade als das 11 das geht und was
besonderes uns haben dann auch noch mal
angreifen geschrieben
[Musik]
sending many messages mein kind dann ist
hier noch so dass da ist der andrang
hier mit der hand hat
2000 jahre später etwas tun die
[Musik]
er wurde bitte den schwanz mache ich
kann nicht erkennen wie jetzt kann ich
das hier neu starten weil mein ganzer
chat ist gerade
ich bin auch raus wer hat denn jetzt
gewonnen wir haben alle geworden ja
freunde das direkte ab ende von dem
video aber bei mir hat der
gefährlichkeit in blau geworden danach
das als distributor das video gefallen
hat das gerne einen daumen hoch oder dem
video hier daher sollten wir öfter
irgendwie skript leo spielen schreibt
gerne in die kommentare martin finden
ich verlegten beschreibung ca
[Musik]